la cifra sigue aumentando
en perú las autoridades elevaron a
11.900 el número de barriles derramados
en las costas del país el gobierno
indicó que se trata de un escenario sin
precedentes en la historia de la nación
con el trabajo ha sido frontal y
contundente al afrontar esta crisis a
mitad de este episodio
a través de todos los organismos la
realidad se está haciendo el trabajo que
no lo está haciendo la empresa en un
principio la empresa española repsol
había dicho que se trataba sólo de seis
mil barriles pero luego de la
información revelada por el ejecutivo
peruano emitió su propio balance
con la información técnica disponible
estamos en disposición de comunicar que
la cantidad de petróleo derramado es de
10 mil 396 barriles y de esto el 35% ya
ha sido recuperado mediante las labores
de limpieza del mar y de las playas
según nuestras mejores estimaciones más
temprano un juez peruano prohibió la
salida durante 18 meses a cuatro
directivos de la refinería entre la
lista se encuentran los nombres de jaime
fernández cuesta el director de la
empresa y el de renzo tejada mckenzie el
jefe el terminal marítimo dos de la
pampilla a los que el ministerio público
ordenó a permanecer en el país para
esclarecer los hechos las
investigaciones continúan para
determinar cuál es la responsabilidad de
la empresa en la crisis ambiental
desatada el 15 de enero tras un tsunami
creado por la explosión de un volcán
submarino en tonga